when you think about that uh what what
type of asset do you think
could be kind of the the breaking of the
dam
in demand like what type of asset would
that take
a little selfishly and self-promotional
but
i obviously think that the republic note
token um
which we we launched the public sale a
few days ago
and glad to share that uh the soft cap
that we put was over subscribed within
just a couple of days
uh but we have a very large community
and our token i should describe it a
little bit
is a profit sharing token that is when a
company on republic sees an exit
we realize some proceeds and we pay that
proceeds out to the token holders
proportional to the token that they have
so if uh someone buys a republic token
and robinhood a spacex goes public in
two years
this is going to be a very small amount
but an amount
being paid out to to the token voters
that is relatable meaning people can
look at it and say
here's a regulated business with
clear revenue with over 150 million
dollars have been invested
and they have upside in these deals and
we have this community which is 700 000
and growing so we do think that the the
our user base alone is larger than many
exchanges uh
and so we have the ability to to
innovate itself
feel that liquidity and demand but we
are just you know basically the first of
many to come
our goal is to identify major
movies sport league studios real estate
portfolio
help them tokenize and make it available
to to the masses
um but yes i mean the the the use case
for tokenization
i think are just countless uh and uh the
concern is
once the floodgate has been open
and people see the value in it how can
the system
accommodate you know let's see all at
once
uh 20 different very large enterprises
wanting to tokenize but that's a good
problem to have
for sure and maybe explain a little bit
more about uh the republic note token
because i saw a couple of announcements
uh
online but my understanding is an
investor can come in they buy the token
all of that money gets pulled together
uh it gets
invested into deals that go through the
republic platform
and then as uh there's profits it gets
distributed back
on a pro-rata basis to investors or am i
misunderstanding that
yes no no i there's no reinvestment in
this one sense uh
think of the easiest way of looking at
it is this if i may use an analogy
of you know back in 1996 if amazon
were to say that hey we're gonna issue
pre-minted
fix 800 million token and then we're
gonna put 25
of our revenue from there on whenever 25
revenue is generated they're gonna make
a distribution out to these
tokens on an evergreen basis at the time
probably was a modest uh distribution
uh but obviously fast forward 20 years
each of those tokens would be i don't
know how many hundreds of thousands of
dollars in value
the same concept here which is we
pre-made
a fixed pool of token and then on a
perpetual basis
we will make distribution of profit back
to the token holders
what are those profits we have an upside
we
every company that raises on republic we
have an upside potential
whenever a company sees an exit that
upside potential
is realizing cash that cash is paid back
through a stream an issuer and going
back to the token borders
so one way of another way of looking at
it is that when we started out with this
project and where
i think we were binance first portfolio
company we had done
only about 15 raises
and we've raised less than six million
dollars
and even at the time finance was like
there's a potential for this
with the pool of future profit and asset
over a year and a half two years now is
over 150 million
in total amount raised and the pool of
asset is probably worth at least
20 times what it was in 2018. so if we
continue for two more years it's just
increasingly amplifying an evergreen
basis
yeah that that's awesome and what's
really interesting about this is
uh the profit share uh is basically the
profit of all the successful companies
that go through the republic platform
right because if they're unsuccessful
there will be no profits but
when they're they are successful it's a
way to kind of almost index your
exposure to to a bunch of different
companies it seems like
correct so the the uh the unusual
attribute of that and you know you being
one of the most prolific and known
veterinary capitalists in the space as
well as you know generally speaking
we all know that if you just invest even
if you
were to just invest in one or two or
three deals and no more
i mean there's a high high risk of you
seeing very little of that money back
right
so the name of the game is obviously a
number game
even among the very best venture
capitalists
so what's unusual about the republic no
token is that it gives
note holders indirect exposure on an
evergreen basis meaning at one point
say 10 years down the road republic has
done 15 000 deals
through uh crowd capital that
every note holder as long as you hold a
note when a company
out of that pool exit you're going to
see a payout
which lends itself to a very unusual
token economic
issue that is people will be reluctant
to sell because the moment that if i
hold a note token and i will sell it to
you
uh palm and all of a sudden robin hood
sees an exit
the payout will be to the new note
holder not me
so out of that that that psychology of
wanting to hold on for long-term return
rather than plum and dumb i do think
that it's going to introduce an
interesting but probably a positive
dynamics to to
token economics compared to what we have
seen in the past couple of years
yeah it's super interesting and i guess
how does this impact the traditional
markets right so we see like a coin base
for example
that's been talking about uh or at least
rumored to be talking about potentially
going public
uh i know that brian armstrong
previously had said that like the most
on brand thing would be to
digitize or tokenize the equity of the
business sounds like maybe now they're
exploring the traditional side
at some point it feels like those two
markets like they meet
right and either they merge together and
play nicely or
one ends up winning and the other ends
up losing and so just kind of how do you
think about digital securities
versus traditional market over like a
very long period of time
uh i'm obviously gonna guess uh make big
uh make a
guess here on the decision uh making
process
at coinbase uh but i think at one point
uh the management team at coinbase made
the decision
that hey we're so large now with an
institution
that it's easier to go through the ipo
the traditional going public process
than dealing with digitizing and
digitized tokenized securities
given that the traditional process
there's a clear road map
this less of a risk this less of a gray
area it comes with a lot of hurdle
but it's exactly what you know they are
what they are everyone has people have
done it before
and yes it is a way to provide you know
public access
that said there are still limitations to
the traditional model
in that once and if coinbase is listed
on nasdaq
it's not easy at all for a chinese
resident and ecuadorian resident
peruvian vietnamese to participate they
those people cannot easily buy tesla
today
and they will not be easily uh have
access to
to coinbase in the future i think down
the road
i think it will take probably at least
five years
for the traditional public market to be
digitized and modified by what we will
see
in the sto world but over the next year
or two
the the change in in stos
and digital securities for early stage
companies and
projects i think will pose a serious
or at least raise the serious
conversations for the nasdaq of the
world
because they know that in five years out
they won't have candidates to go ipo
given that people would already have
opted for digital uh
offerings uh much sooner
and so it sounds like it's fair to say
that people can go from
uh traditional non-digitized equity
and digitize at any point right in the
kind of life cycle of the business
but it's much harder if you start out
with digitized equity and kind of this
token structure
to go back to the traditional world
right so at some point once you cross
over it's hard to go back and
and say if i raise money early on
through a digital token structure
as equity to then go get listed on the
nasdaq or the nysc
would be pretty difficult well it is uh
rather than difficult i would say it's
an unknown
and within that kind of highly regulated
war
any unknown poses a risk so i would say
that it's rather than it being difficult
as long as in your structuring of your
digital offering
uh you you know your sdo early on as a
private company
build in there a framework that is good
for investor
good for token holders but gives you the
ability that if you so choose it becomes
so
crucial for the company to go public
traditionally
that you have a way to give return back
to note holders
and basically be able to crawl back
those tokens
in a way that that you know token
holders are happy with
and you know random shares in in return
so there's still ways for you to go
you know to reverse and undo things uh
at least
you know we do see a path for that uh
but that
is a big unknown and a you know a
question in my mind is
whether or not the ipo model will
continue to exist five years out 2025
and above
and and beyond i don't know that you
will see the kind of like
you know uber and coinbase uh ipo that
we
that we are seeing now and we already
see
in the traditional world there's
definitely some movement or change right
so we've seen the
um you know spotifys and the slats do
direct listings we've seen the virgin
galactics go through
these kind of spac acquisitions and and
so there's definitely some pressure
there or some
change it feels like digital securities
is kind of further out than just a one
or two-year
thing but to your point um if it can
solve some of these problems there's a
lot of companies that say why wouldn't i
do that if uh
if it's just a better path and not only
that truly the spac
and the the the ipo process is only
for the coinbase of the world uh and
even then compared to
the 90s the number of companies you know
the number of public companies out there
in the us
i think something like 50 less than it
was like 30 years ago so it
it has been a trend that's like less and
less
you know completely choose to go public
the notion of digital securities and
stos
uh is such that it's usable applicable
to even
seed stage companies and projects
uh so i do think that currently in the
near term
the two models serve very two different
demographics
coinbase is probably the only company
that i imagine that there was ever a
board conversation of should we
tokenize out our equities and and make
it available that way or should we go
public
and they seemingly chose to go public
but for pretty much everyone else that's
not a dilemma that they have to deal
with i don't think